[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
willkommen zum ersten video im neuen
jahr 2017
und bevor ich mit dem rezept starter
wünscht ihr euch natürlich alles alles
gute fürs neue jahr und gesundheit glück
und erfolg und gesundheit wirklich das
wichtigste das neue jahr starten wir mit
einem ganz einfachen rezept heute gibt
es eine italienische rekord orte und das
ganz besondere ist dies auch noch
glutenfrei denn der teig wird nur aus
ricotta eiern und mandeln zubereitet das
sind die hauptbestandteile und im innern
habe ich noch ein paar äpfel mit dabei
die machen den kuchen richtig saftig ein
bisschen zimt und die orangenschale
natürlich und ich brauche auch ganz
viele zutaten dafür und zeigt euch davor
nummer direkt für den blüten freien
mandelkuchen brauche ich zwei äpfel eine
unbehandelte orange viel eiweiß eine
prise salz 270 gramm zucker der mich
schon aufgeteilt in zwei schälchen etwas
vanille extrakt 120 gramm weiche butter
vier eige nen halben teelöffel zimt 300
gramm reporter käse 250 gramm mandeln
die werde ich gleich noch mal ein
untoter mandelblättchen stehen jetzt
erst einmal das eiweiß das kommt in eine
saubere und fettfreie rührschüssel
bekomme ich die prise salz dazu und wird
das eiweiß steif schlagen und sobald es
steif ist gebe ich dann gleich den
zucker mit dazu
das verhindert
das verhindert dass das eiweiß sagt und
verbindet sich später besser mit den
anderen zu kappen
und in der zwischenzeit nämlich schon
einmal messi schälen und den einzelnen
mieter wir verschreiben
[Musik]
der eischnee sitz fertig den kann ich
kurz zur seite stellen und eine zweite
stütze da nehme ich jetzt nur flach höre
da kommt jetzt die weiche butter reihen
gemeinsam mit dem restlichen zucker und
etwas von x-factor fast so viel es gibt
keinen zu viel und den extrakt und es
wird jetzt sind drei bis vier minuten
cremig verrührt und in website kann ich
jetzt schon mal die orangen schale
abreiben
ich schreibe dir so ab weil ich gelernt
habe das nur so einfach weniger druck
ausübt und die weiße schale gar nicht
mit antreten
die weiße haut darunter dieser ein
bisschen bitter wir wollen möchten wir
nicht und außerdem ist sieht man so ganz
genau was man angehen abgegeben
doch es wird die auffangschale
[Musik]
und damit die apple jetzt nicht frauen
werden gebe ich noch etwa zwei bis drei
esslöffel auch raus und sagt mit dazu
[Musik]
wenn die butter zucker mischung ein
geschmeidiges geht es um die eigene buch
einzeln mit dazu
und sobald sie eingeführt sind kommt
auch der rekorder käse dazu
und da ich hier kein flexible habe muss
ich hier am rand einmal kurz die
butterweck schaffen und damit arbeiter
rühren
[Musik]
sobald die zutaten nun geschmeidig
verrührt sind könnt ihr die schüssel
rausnehmen kommen die zutaten reihen die
mandeln habe ich jetzt schon fein
gemahlen sind pulver kommen
die habe ich jetzt kurz unter mit einem
schneebesen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der schnee noch mit rein
erstmal nur im dritten ungefähr und dann
den rest
[Musik]
jetzt will ich die massen meinen
vorbereiteten waren erstmal nur die
hälfte von dem bug ring habe ich auf 24
cm durchmesser eingestellt da kommt
jetzt die hälfte rein da verteile ich
jetzt die äpfel drüber sie habe ich ja
schon mit dem orangensaft vermischt und
mit denen orangenschalen
[Musik]
jetzt die zweite hälfte drüber
die masse könnte jetzt gern auch so ein
bisschen vermischen damit sich die äpfel
noch ein bisschen besser verteilen
[Musik]
und hier verteidigt noch die marke
blättchen trifft und die manche
plätzchen die bäume unter dem ofen so
ein bisschen
und das sieht dann später richtig schön
aus und vor allem werden sie schön
knackig
[Musik]
und so wird der kuchen im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 40 minuten gebacken ich wette
nach einer stäbchen probe machen und
falls es zu dunkel wird könnt ihr auch
die temperaturen bisschen runter stellen
oder den kuchen mit einem sack papier
abschicken
[Musik]
der mandl ricotta kuchen ist abgekühlt
und jetzt kann ich ihnen anschneiden und
sich auch die samira mit dabei und die
darf gleich probieren aber sanierer
möchte heute lieber hinter der kamera
bleiben
ich habe ihn übrigens nur mit süßen
schnee bestreut dass sich der
puderzucker der auf der oberfläche schön
liegenbleibt und schmelz papa nicht
kommen heute probiert die samira hat sie
gerade eben gesagt du wolltest noch
sagen warum der mantel ricotta gucken
heißt oder er hat sich schon richtig
saftig an
[Musik]
der große feinschmecker heft kann ja mal
dran riechen und sagen wir schon recht
rasch handeln
es gibt also noch orange wie toll sie
das macht da kann der papa sich aber
dass scheibe von abschneiden und speck
gut kommt gleich schmeckt gut nochmal
aber ich möchte nicht aufessen und nach
war schleck
[Musik]
so schön saftig oder trocken
und vielleicht noch
ja noch die courage mixtur aus hatte
sicher der wahnsinn
[Musik]
porsche schmeckt sehr gut und vor allem
mag ich dass der kuchen sehr saftig ist
natürlich fällt da jetzt ein bisschen
auseinander beim schneiden das liegt
einfach daran ohne mehl gebacken wurde
und glutenfrei ist aber dennoch ein
[Musik]
das nehmen wir dann in unserer nächsten
sexuelle stunde von stehe erklären wie
man beherrscht naja jedenfalls an ihrer
dachte das nächste mal noch eine frage
überlegen und falls ihr das rezept nach
machen wollt dann könnt ihr es gerne auf
sell ist also selbst woche in nachlesen
das rezept schreibe ich euch dann noch
mal ganz genau und servieren würde ich
in klecks sahne zum beispiel empfehlen
oder eine kugel eis passt auch sehr gut
und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
spaß beim nachbarn und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal bekommen schon immer
auf sachfragen noch eine frage
mal können wir gehen raus
[Musik]